[Music]
marin morris and husband ryan hurd
have us all in our fields the song feels
so
right for us is because we it kind of
feels like that beginning of us
on sunday the couple took the stage
together at the 2021 acms
belting out a beautiful rendition of
their hit song chasing you
[Music]
we got to perform together um check
and won two acm awards so
it's been a pretty banging night banging
sunday night
they appeared to recreate the music
video for their hit song during the
[Music]
performance
e.t caught up with the couple ahead of
sunday's show where they opened up about
performing together for the first time
well this is my first ever uh
opportunity to perform
at the acm so uh that for me is really
cool and to get to do it with marin is
even better
and it kind of takes all the pressure
off of it i don't know if that adds
pressure or takes it off but i don't
feel very much right now
oh that's so good to hear i mean what is
it like sharing the stage with your
husband for this special event
i mean i'm so excited because typically
i'm trying to find him
in the crowd if i'm on stage performing
just so i like have somebody
that i can make eye contact with and now
it's like super easy to find him because
he's on stage with me
another super easy thing for marin to
find two more acms to add to her
collection
the female artist of the year winner got
emotional while accepting the trophy for
song of the year
for her hit track the bones when i wrote
it i was dating my
now husband and it was just a song to
him
and i feel sometimes like songs know you
better than you know them at the time
and i feel like this song has revealed
so many new things to me that i didn't
know were possible
the day i wrote it and this has just
been
a hell of a year e.t caught up with
marin backstage after the show
and she told us why she got emotional
over her win
it's a bit of an older song um for me
in my life but it has taken on such
depth over the years it's sort of like a
fine wine it's like aged
in meaning and in sound and so um yeah
that kind of hit me
tonight on stage just accepting the
award for song of the year because
it's just crazy when your songs
sometimes know you better than you know
them
and this song definitely knew me in a
deeper way
even three four years ago when i wrote
it um than
i did then so i am yeah it's just
it's crazy that songs end up having a
mind of their own